[Music]
make I
feel Victory I know this life for
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value taming giving values
contagious this world are entrepreneurs
we G no value to haters run homie look
what I become I'm the I'm the
one
all right here we go podcast episode
325 um let me kind of get into a couple
things that happened last we were at the
GOP debate last night great we went with
a whole crew it was uh the four four of
us it was in Miami I thought it was the
best set they had out of every single
one of them we've been to Milwaukee
Ronald Reagan we will not be at the Bama
one but uh we were at Miami why why not
the the the set was
insane and uh what the media is saying
was very different than what the vibe
was when you were there matter of fact I
ran a poll last night okay we got a
bunch of other stories we'll talk about
here but I ran a poll last night on who
won the debate now when you look at this
poll this is 144,000 votes so it's not
like it's 500 votes leg it's not 5,000
votes it's not 50,000 votes it's a good
good amount of people to measure it with
144,000 that's a very good sample size
sample size Tim Scott 2.2 Nikki Haley
4.4 Ronda santz 10.3 Viet came out
[Music]
83% on this poll okay fine so you look
at this you're like okay is this exactly
how the audience saw it as well Rob if
you can pull up the opening vivec's
opening on how he you know just
absolutely shook the place up with his
opening statement and what he said if he
can just find out while you're doing
that uh uh I want to I want to read my
uh recap from what I had uh from being
at this debate hang on one second Rob
let me find this here yeah if you can't
find first I'll play this clip and then
we'll go through R just play this clip
watch this why you uh why should you be
the nominee and not the former president
I think there's something deeper going
on in the Republican party here and I am
upset about what happened last night
wait for it we' become a party of losers
at the end of the day was it cancer in
the Republican establishment let speak
the truth I mean since Ron McDaniel took
over as chairwoman of the RNC in 2017 we
have lost 2018 2020 2022 no red wave
that never came we got trounced last
night in 2023 and I think that we have
to have accountability in our party for
that matter Ron if you want to come on
stage tonight you want to look the GOP
voters in the eye and tell them you
resign I will turn over my yield my time
to you and frankly look the people there
are cheering for losing in the
Republican Party think about who's
moderating this debate this should be
Tucker Carlson Joe Rogan and Elon Musk
we'd have 10 times the viewership asking
questions that GOP Primary voters
actually care about and bringing more
people into our party you think the
Democrats we got christien weler here do
you think the Democrats would actually
hire Greg Gutfeld to host a democratic
debate they wouldn't do it and so the
fact of the matter is I mean Krist I'm
going to use this time because this is
actually about you in the media and the
corrupt media establishment ask you the
Trump Russia collusion hoax that you
pushed on this network for years
was that real or was that Hillary
Clinton made up disinformation answer
the question go yes look at her face
look at the face this is how we get I
don't want to be here we need
accountability because this media rigged
the 2016 election they rigged the 2020
election with the hunter Biden laptop
story and they're going to rig this
election accountability let to governor
governor Chris okay pause it right there
by the when he when he gave that speech
the place went insane is that fair
he went straight Savage mode off top we
were sitting with the folks at Rumble to
our right was the Haley Camp Haley Camp
was you would know it's a Haley Camp
anytime Haley said anything they would
scream off the top of their lungs the
stist was on the other side and they had
different folks that was there now
here's the thing the whole thing if you
go a little lower I think he is speaking
to Ron if you go a little lower that
that right after the debate was done R
McDaniel story came out that she called
him an or something if you she
called him scum no no no Haley called
him called him scum she called him an
that's correct that's the story
she called him an uh afterwards
and that was the nicest thing she says
this is done he will not get anything
from us or any kind of money whatever
was some kind of a statement being said
not and people in that area heard what
she had to say so that was that that's
pretty intense right there okay on what
happened now my thoughts and it we'll go
into uh conversations and different
things here's what I think happened uh
if you go to my tweet Rob uh yeah there
you go she's not he's not going to get a
scent from us look at this he's an
total he will not get a
scent from us she sit this at the debate
and others heard her saying this okay so
he not only goes after the establishment
RNC okay Ronald McDaniel went after
establishment mainstream media okay
calling out in their face go right and
afterwards he went after Haley he went
after
a bunch of different people he went
after and at the same time he was yet a
synergist so for me the winner at the
top Was vivec Not only was the unanimous
winner if you can go to the tweet my GOP
breakdown if you can break it down uh go
to one of the tweets you'll see it I
think it's the one that reads the whole
thing yeah go to it right there if you
can show more so Not only was VOR
unanimous winner star was born today he
shined he was loose he was comfortable
yet intense he even gave credit to the
santis and Tim Scott multiple times a
good balance between a fighter leader
and a synergist he kept going on to to
the santis on each break you guys may
have not seen this but while we're there
the every single there was three breaks
every break Vic went to the santis and
spoke to him for 90 seconds out of the
three and a half minute break they had
he would speak to the santis until the
santis would walk
away it was a sign of being a synergist
he kept giving different perspectives
changing definitions of Overdose to
terrorist poisoning when they talked
about Fentanyl and you know all these
other things Rob if you can go a little
lower with that he was so captivating
that if you watch the replay you'd
notice even his opponents were impressed
with him his opponents were watching him
now the santis last week when the santis
was on our podcast it was the highest
score he got off searches on Google if
you can bring that up I don't know if
you saw the data or not oh I'll show it
to you right now great does the the
sandz camp know that I'm I'm sure Brian
is a sharp guy he's a he's a he's a
sharp guy he knows data last week when
he was on on if you go to his Google
score Brandon sended to you uh not this
is not this is that the one what date is
that that is the no that's not the one
cuz that's all three if you just go to
the one where he was on the debate it's
not working if you just press retweet uh
refresh it uh now that's the debate go
back to the other one then it's the
other one Rob yeah look at this one
highest score look where Ron goes bingo
at the highest he hits the 100 Mark he
was one of the most trending wordss on
all of uh Google so look at this blue
being uh uh uh Haley and then r as Vic
for that entire two weeks Vic was rarely
being Googled but after our podcast
that's the day he was here on October
30th boom on fire that's awesome so go
back to the Tweet so the santis for me
believe it or not was the most poised
I've seen him uh I thought he was the
most comfortable he's been he seemed
presidential um he was even funny and
loose at times and uh I actually liked
listening to his perspective you know
and the same STIs I thought out of three
debates this was the best one Haley was
favored to win in my opinion but she
seemed a little rattled and upset she
even called him a scum I mean that's a
you you the guy didn't say anything to
you but the fact that your daughter's on
Tik Tok and why are you calling him a
scum it's a valid question he's asking
um it's as if she came with an agenda
and Vic disrupted her like you have a
game plan for for your game and the
opponent completely throws you off your
game plan I think vivec did that to her
she's by far the best at giving data but
she was a bit off yesterday
mainstream media won't agree with me on
that Christie didn't call out vivec or
anyone else like he did in the first two
debates it's as if he wants to
potentially go and back somebody up so
he didn't want to piss anybody else off
um this was probably his last debate Tim
Scott got the most speaking time out of
everybody I even said right there Tim
Scott got a ton of speaking time but I
found myself thinking I'm at church
instead of a debate seems like a very
nice guy uh but way too bland and uh
this was the best out of three debates I
thought moderators did okay
um but uh yeah so if you go to the media
and see who was the winners and losers
guess what most websites will say the
loser was be yeah weird what isn't that
weird if you go to okay go to go loser
of go to go to any one of them everybody
has vivea as The
Loser winners and losers from the debate
let's see what Hill's gonna say and the
Hill's a pretty credible Source would
you say uh who do they have as their
winners and losers uh Ronda Sanz keep
going do they have it categorized as a
winner and a loser
anyways you talk CK winner n Haley right
you're just a scum so they gave it to
her the santis winner and then go to
Loser all the way at the bot Donald
Trump winner look at the first loser
keep going mix loser number one out of
here like that's these two most
memorable moments of the night were both
uh bad ones for him the attack on
Haley's daughter was the worse and the
misstep also seemed virtually guaranteed
to earn the enmity uh uh of suban Women
Voters whom the GOP badly needs to win
okay ramas Swami's other big moment came
when he called Ukraine's President
Vladimir zalinski and Nazi okay I don't
even remember that and uh I do remember
it but it's interesting how the media
sees this versus um everybody else so
what was yours Tom when you were there
last time who did you think was the
winner uh I thought Viet came out and
showed himself very well I thought
America appreciates it when you walk out
front and you defend your kids um
especially if your kids you know are
being undressed accused America admires
those Armenian moms that went to the
city um Schoolboard meeting in Glendale
California and I think there's a lot of
Americans judged by I I did a small poll
only had about 600 votes but it was the
same thing um it was 90% for Vic I think
he came out he showed himself very very
well and I I thought he was the strong
performer and I really thought that
Nikki Haley was really good coming up
with the stats pulling the stats out of
her head and and and responding to
points but she didn't look like poised
and smooth doing it looked a little like
off a step like like you know like a
Defender who's off a step under the
basket and trying to catch up to the
play I that's kind of the way I felt
about her and I I agree with you I
thought the santis looked presidential
and in the words of one of the three
women at my house boy he finally looked
like a a candidate who disagrees with me
Adam who was yours who did you see like
way ahead were you all V like who did
you see well when we did the predictions
yesterday I I I had VC you did have V I
did have VC I think most of you guys had
you had Ron okay I bro it wasn't even
close Tim Scott snoozefest literally I
think people were sleeping when he was
speaking and his two highlights when he
talked about boys should play sports
against boys that's great um Christie
actually for a guy that we when we were
in California he had good jokes and
energy and he was Donald Duck and
whatever uh he was just kind of just
lame I don't know uh Ron I I we've said
the same thing over and over and over
against Ron great policy guy poised I
get it a little bit higher taller in
person than you know with the boots and
all that but he just doesn't have that
it factor that Riz nobody's like oh
did you hear what Ron said he just
doesn't have it no great Governor I just
don't think he's ready for the world
stage Nikki um poised confident just way
too uh War hawkish for most people I
mean she's ready to go to war in Taiwan
with China she's ready to go into
Ukraine Israel she's I mean she's
looking for fights wants but at the end
of the day I think we saw what VC did
came out the gates in the first debate
guns blazing second debate when we were
there we're like what happened to VC
this third debate I don't know what got
into him I don't know who spoke to him
could have been pbd I don't know I think
it was Pat homeboy said all right bro
I'm just coming out Savage mode here's
something interesting about Ron McDaniel
so if you know anything about the RNC
Who was the the previous chairman of the
RNC was R's prous so he was aligned with
Trump he was a trump guy was he was the
chief of staff first six months of
Trump's White House campaign he was
feuding with scaramucci and ban and he
was out yeah previous to that was
Michael steel he's now an MC MSNBC
contributor but Ronald McDaniel he
basically looked at her she gave a
speech at the beginning of the show yeah
do you remember that was her yeah of
course here's the thing about her do you
know what her maiden name is take a
guess maiden name um maiden name she's
the RNC chick
um bush I won't even give it what you're
not bad you're not close ra Romney
McDaniel she's from the Romney family
did you know that M oh God yeah she's
she's related to M so she's
establishment as it gets now if we know
anything about VC my final Point homeboy
is anti-establishment yeah he's smart
he's capable he's opinionated he's Savvy
he'll show up anywhere he showed up foot
planted in the middle of the RNC and was
like check this thing out and just went
guns a blaze so to me he was was
undoubtedly the winner of the night and
it's no wonder that mainstream media has
him as a
loser Mitt Romney is her uncle herle
there is look guys look at me bringing
some value to the podcast anybody that
names good I like this thanks man
research anybody that names her son of
sporting equipment M it's just whatever
but anyway listen obviously VC I mean
I'm not surp a m sports equipment you
put your baseball fan you to college you
don't know what a m is Tom you're you're
you're a pict du guy geez thanks for
thanks Tom anyway back
V came out like Mike Tyson first round
knockout crapped on everybody he didn't
dude male female kid he doesn't he
doesn't care and I and I I respect it
but I think Pat right off the rip the
fact that he's he called out the media I
think that had a a play in the fact that
they went to Christy a lot and they went
to Tim Scott a lot right called out
Kristen weled her
face she didn't know what to do she was
in she was shell shock but Pat you know
you know I Saw V do he he showed Trump
and this is why they're all going to go
after him that's why he's not winning on
no leftist polls he had that Trump
attitude but he's not winning on
Republican polls well what was that
thing that we Fox didn't have him as the
winner fox said he lost that that to me
they're still all establishment it's
they're all Nikki Haley all them
everything was war everything was
everybody else first VC put us first and
that's the same attitude As Trump had
that's why they that's the they do not
want anybody like that he didn't put
Russia first he didn't put Ukraine he
didn't talk about it's nobody no Israel
no nobody he said America first and
that's why no he's not winning anywhere
because you know this Pat you put us
first and you're you looked upon like
you're you're insane cuz we're supposed
to love everybody except us so I got a
question for you so last night Robert's
with us you know Robert's always got a
different lens r o yeah R so the entire
time I'm like why do they keep going to
Tim Scott and I kept turning around I
one like the guys this guy on 2.0 he
speaks too slow like it's like we just
noticed it upstairs we're watching him
on 2.0 YouTube and it's like as if he's
listening yeah anti you show up the CNN
numbers can you show up the CNN numbers
check this out who spoke the most and
the least okay okay the most last night
was Tim Scott and then Haley and then
Vic and then the Sanz and then Christie
okay I understand Christie why the hell
would Tim Scott speak the most so then
Rob says maybe because
NBC is doing it intentionally to make
the show be so boring that Americans
don't watch it I agree okay maybe it was
an intentional way of getting people say
I can't listen to this anymore move away
do you think NBC is that dumb to realize
that in a business of capitalism if your
sponsors that are paying you millions of
dollars don't get a lot of eyeballs are
going to be okay with you giving it to
the person like what what the audience
wants to see a fight between Haley and
Vic put the top three the top three
should have been who Haley the santis
and vivec Tim Scott should be all the
way at the bottom even below Christie is
where he should have been I agree do you
think there was any motives in them
giving Tim Scott the most eyeballs
absolutely because I don't think the
producers and the political writers and
the political commentators and Lester
hold himself I don't think they give a
rip on this particular show what the
corporate guys are are looking at in
terms of AD dollars they're going to
promote it they're going to get the best
viewership they can but if they I think
if they detect momentum in that show
they will go away from the momentum and
I I felt like didn't it feel like that
after s minutes they kind of pulled away
from thec and they all they also said
also unlike other debates if someone
says your name or makes an accusation
you do not get an automatic 30 seconds
remember that they did say that
beginning yeah they they were saying
that almost trying to kind of control
the flow and so I I think they
absolutely gamed it a little bit I agree
100% And like Brandon was talking about
polls p i don't listen to any any polls
the same polls that had Hillary at 99%
Pat you're a Democrat let me ask you a
question right now you're a registered
Democrat lifelong Trump hating whatever
it's going to be tough it's going to be
hard so Pat you saw this debate in that
lens as a Democrat out of everybody here
who would you want if you had to pick if
you if you had to be like all right I'll
deal with this so you want a weak team
to play in the Super Bowl well that b
basically what I'm saying is p cuz they
know like Biden whatever Chris Christie
would be my number one yeah Chris
Christie would be one because he hates
Trump and I if I'm a Democrat I want to
hear anybody that's trashing Trump the
most it's him then who I would probably
want to hear is Haley because she's at
least a woman so and her position on
pro-life pro-choice is the best one
amongst everybody then I would probably
Listen to Tim Scott then I would
probably listen to The Scientist and
vivec would be the most annoying person
on that stage if Democrat yeah 100% And
then or no 1,00% 1,00% I would fully
agree with you I would just swap VC and
D santis I don't think Democrats have
any love for disantis well you don't
think so over only Reon top because six
we abortion the only reason I put vivea
at the top is because Democrats can't
stand capitalist in you know made your
own money calling out
anti-establishment the stist didn't even
that day when we had him on the podcast
I said look you're like a hybrid you
could some people think your
establishment you know and and that's
kind of where you are he didn't really
correct me and even in my intro he
corrected me twice so that is the one
area he didn't correct me by
establishment you just kind of let that
one go you were going to say something
Tom yeah I think I think what the
Democrats don't want they do not want
successful people of color they want
entitled people of color full stop they
don't want successful people of color no
they don't want to go against VC VC
becomes a symbol S not no yeah VC
becomes a exactly what they don't want
you know people who are Democrats who
were are just there casually haven't
really thought it over let's play this
the econom play the clip of Tik Tok play
this clip off Tik Tok check this out I
just texted it to you uh you should have
it this is the actual exchange between
the two of them when uh what do you call
it when uh Vic calls out Nikki Haley's
daughter and just look at Nikki Haley's
eyes she is not happy
watch this go forward RIS Swami uh we've
talked about this you campaign on Tik
Tock how do you get Tik Tok banned if
you use it well I I I want to laugh at
why Nikki Haley didn't answer your
question which is about looking at
families in the eye in the last debate
she made fun of me for actually joining
Tik Tok while her own daughter was
actually using the app for a long time
so you might want to take care of your
family first preing adult daughter the
next generation of Americans are using
it and that's actually the point you
have her supporters
cing here's the truth the easy answer is
actually to say that we're just going to
B one we got to go further we have to
ban any us company actually transferring
us data to the Chinese here's a story
most people don't know Airbnb hands over
us user data to the CCP now that's a
us-owned company so this is the problem
when you have Republicans that
temporarily go the way the winds blow
and now it's popular to talk tough on
China when she was UN Ambassador called
them literally her words not mine our
great friend you can't be fair weather
fans of the right policy get to the root
CA even us companies in Silicon Valley
are regularly doing it cut the virtue
signaling the fact of the matter is
Democrats are on Tik Tok today the only
person one of the few people who is
putting up content the way the actual
algorithms work speaking for pro-israel
views or
others more Republicans will join it
stop us companies from turning over data
to Chinese
compies by the way and think about it
you think of her daughter what do you
think you think she's a child 8 years no
she's 25 years old it's not like she's a
kid talk about my daughter she's an
adult and she's on it and it's all I
mean it's all good but it's like I don't
mean it like that Vinnie is check this
out I assumed that she had younger kids
I don't know why yeah as soon as you he
don't talk about my kid you think it's
an 8-year-old that's watching you know
people falling on by she's she's she's
an adult it's her child but she still
you know she's an adult meaning she
doesn't have any right to tell her
daughter what to do and not to do she's
25 years old she do what the hell she
want but but just at the end look at Joe
Biden and Hunter Biden you think he told
him smoke crack maybe
maybe maybe but it's just it's just it's
funny to see how what one side thinks
the winner is and what they're pushing
on it I want to show you guys what New
York Times did and how they ranked Vic
but before we do do that let's go to our
sponsors real quick go ahead Rob so look
I've been in the financial industry
since 911 the day before 9/11 and I've
owned stocks bonds mutual funds real
estate crypto gold you name it I've
owned it but the one thing that's very
important part of my portfolio all these
years is gold I love having a percentage
of my network in Gold that I have access
to in case of many different things
that's why we chose to work with our new
sponsor American Hartford gold if you
have retirement funds that you cannot
afford to lose American Harford gold
will ship physical gold or silver
directly to your door also if you have
retirement funds that you can't afford
to lose now is the time to call American
Harford gold a precious metal dealer you
can trust they have the finest products
amazing customer service and a buyback
commitment they've earned a five-star
rating from thousands of reviews and an
A+ from the Better Business Bureau tell
them I send you and they'll send you up
to $5,000 worth of free silver on your
first order so click on a link in the
description or call
866939 6984 again
6984 fantastic Rob did you get the what
I just texted you there with the picture
or no
Rob did you see that or no I did not
okay so check this out I'm gonna send
this to you this is New York Times this
just tells you like how they're doing
this and and how they're giving credit
to who and who they don't like obviously
New York Times who do you think they
picked as the winner New York New York
Times New York Times who do you think
they picked as the winner New York Times
would give like a Chris Christie the
winner I would say Ron Ron I'm not going
to say anything cuz I read it okay so
let's show this Rob let's show this Rob
what do you think what do you think I
said Christie he say chrisy probably
Haley though okay who do you think they
have last V okay I want you to see this
okay Rob is it pulling up or no it's not
okay let me do it this way here for you
to see it because I I I it's it's very
very interesting to me how nobody picked
this guy and and they straight up are
because now here's the other question
you got to ask because it's easy to be
like well you know they're idiots and
their establishment all this other stuff
there's many times like you know these
guys are not saying Trump's not the
winner look at that New York Times right
there okay winner then they have it's
from right to left so you see the 10 on
the bottom is that did better yeah so
Haley's first what Den is the santis
then it's chrisy then Tim Scott last Vic
they gave him a two who they gave him a
two who do you think's doing this
poll Centrist this is a freaking leftist
but that's not the point these same
people have Trump all the way as the
winner meaning gets not even even CNN is
like look this is not even a race
Trump's got a 40 plus point lead all
these other guys are fighting for the
silver medal why is vivec
last why Tom what why is vivec glass on
these polls Fe a
AR fear I believe that they that is the
kind of snap and gumption that they
don't want to face and yeah being I
honestly believe that that is the I
think they see in that little bits of
thing remember the big surprises that
have come out we've only had one so in
my
lifetime as I was barely born when
Kennedy was elected but I have been
reading that there hasn't been a
surprise candidate the way John Kennedy
was until Barack
Obama and I think that some people
watching are thinking man this is the
kind of guy that could be a surprise and
they don't want anything to do with it
and Pat think about it the two things
the main things that I took away from
him too he's 38 years old okay let's say
Obviously let's say Trump wins he'll be
42 the next time comes around he's
anti-china he wants to hold China
accountable and guess what he's the only
one that was like anti-war nowh
everybody else on that stage was like we
got to get involved we got to go to R
everybody wanted to fight because that's
where the money's at is there any money
in peace do you think do you think by
the next election that China moves on
Taiwan
I by the next one yeah in this year yeah
I think so by 28 I think so I like what
Chris had to say about 42y old guy who
is right about that 100% so I think I
think the fact that he's pro-america
anti-war he's a threat there's no money
in peace watch this one watch this
exchange go for
it Republican party is not that much
better you have the likes of Nikki Haley
who stepped down from her time at the UN
bankrupt or in debt is was her family
then she becomes a military contractor
she joins the board of Boeing and
otherwise and is now a multi-millionaire
so I think that that's wrong when
Republicans Do It Or democrats do it
that's the choice we face do you want a
leader from a different generation who's
going to put this country first or do
you want Dick Cheney and 3-in heels Cas
we've got two of them on
stage Senator the fact of the M woo we
couldn't hear that I didn't hear that
last line right there two of them he did
a say it three in CHS with two but Pat
you notice what I said America first and
you cannot have that attitude here you
can't and by the way can you find her
response because she does respond to
that see if it's on the bottom of the
Tweet
Rob can you explain the response nobody
can explain the response I didn't get it
but anybody that's weap or something
like Amun ammunition like you're going
to throw a like no she said a weapon a
weapon yeah no she said ammunition so
what is she going to throw a a shoe it a
scar Saturday morning but I I use it as
ammunition like a tra well you ever been
kicked by one of those five and shields
oh no it's hor yeah what do you mean
I've been kicked the back why have you I
was on the floor and the guy that I was
fighting his girlfriend kicked me in the
back for no reason things happen I had
him walk up and down my back but I had
toay extra for that
Tom look I think what did you say Tom
what did Tom to pay extra for the heel
walk on the back I said I had him walk
up and down my back but I had to pay
extra Tom I knew you're some kinky freak
white you know he is you know you have
that or no Rob do you have that clip or
no play that go for here we go like to
say they're 5 in heels and I don't wear
them unless you can run in them um what
that was a call out with the S two of
you on second thing that I will say is I
wear heels they're not for a fashion
statement there for ammunition what we
need to be doing for Iraq and Syria is
if anybody can tell me what she meant by
it it's like you know reading a certain
section in scripture you don't
understand it you're like you go to
Google you're like translation I still
don't know what she meant by do you
think she you think she meant to say as
a weapon she says watch what I'm going
to you know how they say after school
I'll see you after school so after
debate yeah meet me after after debate I
think she's just such a Warhawk that the
first thing on her mind is a fight is a
war it just battle so she's like heals
all right that's a weapon ready to go so
she goes to the war wordss you know guns
tanks Subs ammunition it just pulls them
out automatic she her Contracting she
made money she was on boing and like
he's he's giving stuff that you had no
idea about that just back to V real
quick he's like basically the young
Brown skinny Trump that's exactly and
he's a lot more palatable than Trump is
as far as the abrasiveness and I mean
for you for you is we love the crazy
maniac all of a sudden we Vinnie you
didn't like Trump four years ago but
okay you've came around all right I
didn't like Trump four years ago yeah
you're now you're wearing Trump socks to
debate it's cool you're on maggot it's
got I love you be be honest inside you
miss him tell Adam Adam iing secretly
hold on hold on what everything Happ
when he walk hold on when he walked into
the UFC when he walked into the UFC what
did Adam turn into Adam was like man and
look at this
fight by the way the best the best
article here very insightful Nikki Haley
stomped when debate moderate asks asks
her to list some country she wouldn't
invade babyon be that's so so good Oh
Canada yeah yeah I I just uh for anyone
that hasn't been to a debate and seeing
basically democracy work in front of you
it's actually amazing go sick it feels
really cool to be in a thing like this
and just mixing it up we saw mayor SW
Suare shout out to him we saw Ruben
obviously the rumble guys it's it's a
really an amazing feeling it was great
to see this like it's it's and this was
by far in a way so much better than the
California debate that was a show
like we could literally walk on stage
Tom and I were on stage yeah at January
6th the stage
every stage and said hi to the vet oh I
remember you guys can you imagine if you
look closely you guys are standing there
suited up we have two new
candidates this was so much more
professional it was so much more just
Adam could we have taken selfies at not
close we were taking selfies with I
slapped Chris Christie on the ass in
California what nwork I ended Mike
Pence's campaign with a viral tweet
bigger hand than I thought what network
was doing that one do you remember cuz
this is NBC that was uh univ oh univ
there it's open border hey man everybody
get on stage hey
okay put on your head come on
man poor guy trying to start it dude un
was in charge are you serious these guys
had snipers this was NBC listen why
don't we go to something like a little
bit more lighter uh with what Hillary
had to say here on The View okay
motivational rap if you can play this uh
uh when she speaks it's just the world
gets Cal her voice is like a soothing by
the way which voice can you go with for
four years rank it Hillary Clinton
camalo or Nikki Haley you have to listen
one of those three voices could be the
president that you have to listen to for
four years is this the the old Mary F
kill game I'm just curious like pick
which one is the least to the one that
you're okay with go Haley Hillary kamla
I cannot no he said least least Hillary
oh no no no no no no I then I go the
other way kamla Hillary haly I can't do
Kamala I just can't oh my God this is
wait oh my God this is Haley Hillary
comma like that what's that oh my God
this like all horrible okay I would I
would rather die than listen to Hillary
Clinton's voice then it' be kamala's
cackle and then Nikki Haley third oh my
God just you saying that really bother
sounds like a for actually Haley doesn't
have
a you what you say you're scum scum scum
of the earth here let's listen to a
pleasant voice go ahead Rob people would
get legitimately
elected and then they would try to do
away with elections and do away with
opposition and do away with a free press
and you could see it in countries where
well Hitler was duly elected right right
and so all of a sudden somebody with
those Tendencies though dictatorial
authoritarian Tendencies would be like
okay we're going to shut this down we're
going to throw these people in jail and
and they didn't usually Telegraph that
Trump is telling us what He intends to
do wow and people believe her is it over
well he looked at her didn't he look at
her wait a minute didn't he look at her
to debate and say because you'd be in
jail oh my God that was hands down that
was one of the best moments in all of
debates hands but like I know Reagan had
his moments when but that when Donald
Trump when she was like you know it's
awfully good that with not somebody like
with the temperament of Donald Trump
isn't President of United States oh can
you please hear this Pat please can we
hear it awfully good that someone with
the temperament of Donald Trump is not
in charge of the law in our country
because you'd be in
jail and he turns
around that was the moment where his
fate was sealed that they were going to
throw his ass in jail 100% just know
that actually a good point yeah that was
it that was it just when you start
saying things like that to establishment
Hillary Clinton believe me they're gonna
start digging up some things God by the
way as far as the the KLA thing look
where she
Hillary at least I would say she's smart
now is she Mak of valiant is she
Sinister is she up to no good she's not
an idiot she's a triple word IDI Kamala
is not smart enough to even be Mak
ellian space she slept her way to the
top in California from what I hear Ask
Judge Joe Brown I that's what we've
heard about him he's actually the meme
right the guy with the big the black bar
isn't he the
meme go ahead Tom oh my gosh
are we done on this question everybody's
by the way how many text message did you
get like super important message you
have to see this open it up now and you
open it up that black dude with the and
it's like oh man my mom my mom sending
me stuff I'm like Mom what's your
problem she like it's funny open email
Mom you that I I don't know what I I
don't know what I can add to
that nothing about three
Ines we were just talking about K Hill I
about that I I think it's so you either
have the unbearable or the makan or you
get the war hawk and so I I go with the
Warhawk you know you want the
Warhawk between Haley and and Clinton
and Camala yeah you said the least you
wanted I you
know who knows who knows what's going to
happen with uh what is by the was
Hillary promoting a book Rob when she
was on what was she
promoting was she promoting a
documentary of uh what was that I'm not
sure let me take a look I thought it was
like a documentary of how galain Maxwell
got killed she oh she's actually alive
I'm sorry
mistake she's and a fun fact P she's
doing 20 years they just had an article
that she's complaining about moldy food
but isn't it crazy though Epstein
arrested you know suicided and and she's
in jail forever but what about all the
clients are they not going to care about
going after all these clients that were
using all these underage people that
they were having sex with are we not
going to go after that list what are you
talking that's Whitney web's job my
friend no what I'm saying is Pat so they
caught the sex trafficking King guy the
you know Epstein Island he's gone right
they arrested her what about all the
people that were their clients are we
not are they're not going to go after
the people the black book the book or I
mean there's a list everybody that was
there flight logs yeah well are we not
going to go after the people that use
their services who's we what do you mean
America the government I mean I'm just
waiting like where are the arrests I
know the prince what was his name was it
Albert Prince William Prince who's the
one that got in trouble with prince
Andrew prince Andrew that's yeah and the
queen was like you know what his
punishment was Andy you know his
punishment was for for being with the
underage girl you're losing your Royal
privileges people aren't going to call
you whatever in public we still got to
go after those people check this out
here's the CNN one where uh uh uh he's
they're not going to this is not the
whole clip where he's talking what's
that what's this girl's name on CNN
what's her name on that's Dana Bash Dana
Bash on CNN Dana Bash on CNN and they're
talking to uh uh to Vic it's like well
you know this is why this is and you
know she's like that's not true that's
not been verified that's not how do you
know that's not it's so funny that they
they really don't like this guy they
don't no she's got her producer in the a
denying these things and spinning and
and yeah because he's talking about what
Pat he's talking about um
Joe bid he because he basically said
last night Joe Biden he goes we're not
stupid we all know including the left
Joe Biden is not running just be honest
it's going to be Gavin Nome or he even
said Michelle Obama at one point didn't
he this is it Pat this is the one uh how
many seconds is that no yeah play this
one go ahead play this one this the one
but what I'm saying is as a republican
candidate I can't just call out
Democrats on their corruption I've
called out the hunter Biden corruption
from Ukraine and the $5 million bribe
and I will continue to do that I
there no evidence to support no evidence
to support he was paid a $5 million from
bisma if he was
corruption but if he was but I just want
might be an allegation where there's no
evidence to back that up Daniel
literally just talked about this on the
air absolutely there's a what what would
you say here's what you say what what uh
proof did you have when for three and a
half years you said there's 100% proof
about Russia well she's like guy fact
did I go the other way say what proof
you have it wasn't a bribe yeah go ahead
go ahead ra and testimonial evidence to
suggest it you have US senators saying
they've received information the the
investigations are proceeding as we
speak but that is corruption in the
Democratic party that I have called out
and I think it deserves to be called out
in the Republican party as well no evid
no I not
ad evidence but well look Chuck Grassley
ask Chuck Grassley for the actual
recordings that are actually turned over
fromis we have nobody has seen it yeah
yeah look at look at why haven't they
released and I think whether it's one
thing I was to say is bipartisan Point
whether you're Joe Biden or Nikki Hal
release your tax returns be completely
open about where you've made your money
the American people deserve to know I
did something early in this campaign
that frankly people in both parties
should be doing I put out 20 years of
tax returns I understand why people
don't do it but that's the kind of
honesty we need in both parties and wow
he put 20 years out of his tax yeah he
put it out and they were asking him the
other day hey why' you make $800,000 and
you ask for a scholarship why would you
ask for scholarship when you got an
$800,000 he says you ever worked in
private Equity you ever worked in
Investment Banking you get your bonuses
end of the year when I applied I didn't
have any money I didn't have the bonuses
yeah but the year before you made
$200,000 and he's going yeah I made
$200,000 year before I to make
$800,000 but he's just straight up
openly talking about I love him but by
the way you know his net worth allegedly
six $800 million $800 million $800
million by age 38 dude yeah guy's a
beast man there are so many reasons why
the establishment would hate a guy like
this Y young confident went to the
schools they went to took to debate
classes knows exactly the game they play
has his own money doesn't need your
money doesn't need your endorsement went
to podcast didn't need mainstream media
he went from podcast to mainstream media
inviting him um it's it's a it's an
ideal candidate for the establishment
and not like yeah they think they've
seen the movie before with Obama and it
makes them nervous and speaking of
establishment Dana Bash I mean she's
been she's one of the faces of CNN by
the way you know who she was married to
Jeremy Bash that's what she got her name
Jeremy bash was the chief of of the CIA
initially this was uh in the early 2000s
then she married John King who's one of
the more politically Savvy guys on CNN
she now she co-hosts uh State of the
Union with Jake Tapper yeah she's a hat
she's just I I'm not going hack I'm just
saying she's part of the establishment
an establishment hack she bro for her to
cut him off like at this point it's
completely obvious what Hunter and Joe
Biden were doing like and if you try to
like she's cutting him off because she
doesn't want the words to come out of
his mouth we're not stupid they just
sent subpoenas for Hunter his brother
and one other guy about but again
nothing's going to happen brings up a
really good point is that you could have
anybody Host this NBC debate and you go
with Lester Holt okay he's kind of
vanela I mean oddly enough even though
he's black and then you have Kristen
Welker so I mean he does bring up a very
good point that you you could like would
the DNC ever have Greg Gutfeld or hanity
or Tucker ever host one of their debates
no so I I guess you know main this is
this isn't even cable this isn't CNN
this is NBC this is as Legacy mainstream
media as it gets to host the RNC
interesting how how much you think how
much you think this format is going to
be changed in the next 4 8 12 years or
do you think 12 years from now still
going to be the same thing oh I'm fully
convinced it's going to change in in how
long in four eight or 12 years I would
say four years might be a little too
soon I would say say in the next 8 to 10
years this is going to be and change to
what well look if even look at it now
who was the broadcasting partner
streaming partner it was Rumble yeah
Rumble we sat next to Chris and the
whole Rumble team shout out to those
guys if you told me four years ago
Rumble would be broadcasting the RNC I
be you're out of your mind Who the
hell's Rumble but things are changing so
I think I think four years it could be
actually happen that quickly I think two
things are going to change in four years
I think you're going to see an evolution
of the moderators I think and not
because VC is suggesting it but because
people on podcasts are demanding it I
think you're going to see moderators
change I'd like to see you moderate I'd
like to see moderate I'd like you know I
would I would not mind I'd like to see
Tucker moderate I'd like to see a series
so I think moderators is going to change
because people are demanding it
especially the people are paying test
podcast number one number two I think
it's going to change is I think the
timing and the and the venues this is
pure establishment you walk in there and
there's everybody from the RNC everybody
from The High donors I want to see
bigger venues where more regular
Americans can get in the door and I
think you're going to see that change
next time those are my two predictions
check this out right here Rob just
pulled it up news Nation anchor
Elizabeth Vargas and talk show host
Megan Kelly will be uh the moderators at
December 6th in Alabama and and who's
that who's free who's the other one p
Wasington Johns Elana Johnson Washington
free beac is a it's a very old but very
small newspaper oh got you well I covers
oddly enough politics three women not a
man not a single man as the moderator
that's so sexist I don't think I'm gonna
be able to watch it I just ridiculous so
you so you really think they're going to
go away from this this is the only way
they're going to go away from this here
here's what I think the only way they're
going to get away from this format is if
in the next four eight years there's
such a massive disruption in Cable News
Network with the kind of money they're
making and big Pharma ads going through
where they can't afford to do it anymore
that they're simply saying you know what
we got to go digital guess what we're
going to do it this way we're going to
do it this way we're going to do it this
way but do you think it's going to be
still the two second two- minute answers
the one minute answers the you know 90
second type of answers or do you think
it's going to be actually a long form
type of a debate well that's been debate
format going back 150 years of of
college so that the origin of this was
the discipline debate you know you flip
a coin you draw straw and then you read
a single question you answer it I rebut
and then you get a followup and you do
that eloquently if you go back and look
at Kennedy and Nixon they did it very
nicely even even Carter you know and and
Reagan did it nicely it got a little
more out of hand you know Clinton's
second term where people started
interrupting each other going a little
crazy but that's been like debate class
101 that's been the way we've T debate a
long time make your point receive a
rebuttal provide a follow follow up and
then let the audience or the professor
decide meanwhile while this is going on
yesterday Trump has given a speech
couple miles away from where the GOP
debate was in haia haia packed
jam-packed place and taking shots left
and right I think Sarah hakabe spoke
there I think Junior spoke there he was
at the event and Junior made uh some uh
uh go ahead he was funny Junior made a
couple comments about uh you know what
did he say about the lipstick and
something else as well he got lipstick
on his collar yeah he got lipstick on
his collar just for my wife it's okay
it's okay what do you think Trump is
thinking right now while he's watching
this you think Trump is sitting there
you know thinking to himself okay let me
see who this guy Vic's gonna be you
think Trump at all even has any thoughts
of Vic or Haley as someone that he would
bring on on his team that's a good
question well because Pat isn't he right
now with uh uh what's her name Carrie
Lake he's with her and who else was he
with he was with two
two yeah pet was there but I like that's
a very good question Pat I think
watching this like you said this
yesterday too he's watches everything
he's on he he he keeps his foot to the
fire and he's and he's watching all
these people I think in that group he's
trying to see who's a Ron's not a dude
none of them are threats but I do think
after seeing what he he consistently
hears from VC and VC never bashing him
kind of sounding like him I think it's
VC or krie lake to be like a vice dude
could you imagine Trump and VC as
President and Vice President and then
just follow his lead and then when
Trump's gone for good so I know Adam
will be happy then it'll be it'll be
eight years of VC no that would be that
would be amazing I don't see VC being a
number two guy at this point at this
point I mean he has come out and clearly
said he's not a number two guy that's
why he's running for the number one I
think Carrie lake is positioning herself
as the next Mike Pence Trump SI ofan
whatever but in this situation unless
unless Trump gets kidnapped by aliens
and he's gone nobody's there's no
everybody's number two so what does he
you're saying that V will just kind of
chill out in the political world I just
don't think he would be interested in
being the vice president he said that
I'm just using his words for him as far
as what Trump is focusing on I think
there's in these three things in order
number one rallies campaigns he loves
that stuff he's in high alyah sweating
his ass off just having the time of his
life Hees fall that's number one number
two I think is the legal drama that he's
dealing with I think that's number two
and a dist third is the JV uh Republican
candidate uh debates I don't think he's
really focused on it I think he knows he
has it locked up unless the legal drama
basically supersedes that my opinion I
agree with much of that I think that
that if you narrow the field the VP is
to only those who are on the stage last
night that VC's probably the only one
that doesn't have so much broken glass
that Trump wouldn't select them yeah VCA
has never said one bad thing about Trump
correct so of the four on the stage only
V I think is selectable too much broken
glass with everybody else but then going
Beyond it there's Carrie Lake but I
honestly think the VP would be something
Trump is not he is a pure Alpha leader
he selects a number two because they
tell him he has to otherwise Trump trump
just runs right but sir you need to have
a vice president all right I'll be right
back yeah okay I got one he's fabulous
you hav't going to see this guy you know
not bad Tom you're getting better man
still number one but I not bad but I
mean seriously I think that's I think
that's how Trump runs and I think when
when it all comes to the end he'll pick
somebody he'll think about the states
he'll take you know Don Jr and other
people kind of talking to him and he'll
go but um I'll tell you the fact that
there are that many people in hiia and
you
you the DNC and the Democrats they
better hope that these these legal
things stick because they're not
dropping him in the polls you know oh
he's down two points in the poll two
points 60 days before Iowa and Iowa is
in the bag that's like saying I won the
football game by 26 instead of 28 it
doesn't matter you won and you said next
but but Tom with the legal thing we
heard I heard that he could still be in
jail felon and still be the president so
what's all this like is there something
in this legal proceedings that they
could just grab one thing and say you're
you cannot run as a president first of
all he's going to be guilty of a major f
yeah but and that's in the polls he's
going to that's how we like our
candidates is what Vin trying to say no
what I'm trying to say is it doesn't
disqualify him from running for
president so what I'm saying is all this
legal stuff that's happening is there
something either than a felony charge
that sticks that can make him not
run I don't think there's anything that
can make him not run or unless they put
him in a Cell no there there is
something is not putting him on the
ballot because you saw in Colorado that
that was something they were
contemplating Minnesota the left l leing
state of Minnesota they actually just
approved him being on the ballot yeah so
you know they're doing all the
everything they can to you know pull
some Shenanigans here didn't Superior
Court flip that back an hour later oh
did they I thought that I just read the
headline I mess I guess the sub headline
did they flip it again what's it say Rob
what's it say even if Trump trump is
convicted with 91 fellon accounts 44
Federal 47 State and stands charge he is
still qualified under the Constitution
to run for and become the 47 president
of the United States if he is
disqualified under section three however
he doesn't get out of the Starting Gate
there you go that section provides
important part that no person shall hold
any office under the United States who
having previously taken an oath as an
officer of the United States to support
the Constitution shall have engaged an
Insurrection or Rebellion God that's
what they're doing isn't it great given
Aid or Comfort to enemies thereof wow so
that is that so that is why they're
using the word ins
a great great point and that's why when
they knew it was coming and they were
asking for National Guard they were like
wait a minute don't answer Let It Go to
because that's what they're going
to have to get them that's exactly why
Pelosi and all them didn't call they
didn't get the National Guard they let
hold on they told everybody let them let
them go let them go in that's exactly
why they there not even a rebellion now
you see the corrupt FBI conspiracy
theory wow it's not a conspiracy I don't
like that word
real that's why people say oh it was the
corrupt FBI because they wanted this yes
they wanted this this and this so they
could that's a great Point label at ins
pbd I want to go back to the the VP
nomination when you get a second go for
it I want to see who you think is most
likely to be Trump's VP because you know
if you're the CEO you're the leader
you're the founder of the company the VP
is kind of like the what the COO they're
kind of handling everyday operations if
you will who do you think was best
suited for that that because if you look
at Pence up until literally the last day
that Trump was President Mike Pence was
as boot licking and as uh up Trump's
brown nose ass as it possibly gets
meaning he was playing his part I don't
mean that in a negative way now
everyone's off off Pence who do you
think that next person would be for
Trump um listen this the only difference
on on what what what I'm processing on
how he would make the decision on this
if you're a if you're on your first term
as a president deep down inside what's
your biggest fear an embarrassment to be
a one-term president okay you fear being
a one-term president because you know
who was the last two one-term presidents
senior and Carter I don't want to be
okay so you're kind of going through
that process right so what do you
typically do on your first term not
everything you do enough but you don't
do everything because you want to have a
two- term because most presidents who
get elected to president they're
thinking Legacy first I don't know if
Trump's thinking that maybe he is maybe
he's not um but at the same time I think
a part of him knowing the fact that he
is a guy that wants to compete and wants
to be the best he probably didn't do
everything on the first term now on the
second term guess what you are on your
second term you don't give a on
your second term you're going to go do
everything and anything you can in four
years and then be like I'm done somebody
else come and take this thing over and
you want that person that takes you over
to be one of your guys kind of like
Obama wanted Biden because it's one of
his guys right like a flag carrier you
wanted to be your guy that you can call
and you have a conversation with and
they call you etc etc
so uh I think the Pence was a strategy
for the first one I don't think it's
going to be the strategy for the second
one that he's going to go find a person
like Pence I think second person's got
to be somebody that you think can take
it for8 years um and and and that's why
that eight years it's got to be who's it
for Trump for Trump you mean four no no
the eight after your after the eight
after you're out so his eight you got to
take somebody that's a pence is not
going to win you can't pick a pence yeah
you know if he picks a pence type
personality he's not thinking after
eight years he's thinking whoever's
going to be the eight years is going to
be somebody else that's going to come up
that maybe isn't the person he picks as
a VP but I think that's a risk because I
yeah I I don't know if they're gonna let
this guy be the president Vinnie I don't
I don't know and and what I mean by that
is even if he becomes the president the
way Trump is Trump is the type of guy
that wants to walk outside he's not
hiding he wants to be outside he wants
to golf he wants to go do his thing he
wants to go out there and talk he wants
to go be around people he wants to shake
hands he wants to go to dinners he's not
trying to avoid the Limelight and live a
life of fear he's a Target if if they
fear this guy's going in and he's going
to take a part of their life away from
them these establishment type of people
they cannot let this guy be the
president dude the 91 felony counts
never in the history 44 Federal yeah 47
States section three using the word
Insurrection the people who came up with
this idea right here do you know how
brilliant they are this is this is
probably a lawyer like the one in ruter
that told the whoever it was in the 70s
about the Reco case on how to go take
the mob and then Rudy giulian and goes
finds this lawyer some lawyer contacted
these guys that hates imagine how many
thousands of liberal professors there's
out there that hate Trump that are
lawyers are saying this is how you get
him this is the word you have to use
this is the category of this keep saying
the word Insurrection this is the only
way we can get rid of them exactly the
same way they went after certain people
using that these guys were brilliant
lawyers who hate them to want to take
this guy down they know the 91 4447
that's just purely marketing it's not
going to do nothing but the three the
section of three that's that's the one
and the set and the setup to make it go
down pass so they could go and and every
news every news station in lock step
were like oh my Steve Schmid's loser ass
the worst day since 911 shut the hell up
that same attitude is exactly that they
made it seem like it was the end of the
world was that one day of everybody
going there and protesting unbelievable
that's an amazing thing to see cuz now
it makes all makes sense it ain't felony
no whatever that word right there
Insurrection wow what a Pat that's a
methodical law those are lawyers going
through all the fine print and somebody
went Bingo right there I wouldn't put it
as an Insurrection I think they used
that quite tactically I would still say
it's not a great day no but it wasn't it
wasn't like a day of Pride how can you
call Insurrection nobody had a gun
nobody people were going to hold on Adam
you think people were going to take over
the government and like the next day be
like yeah give me a break that
Insurrection to me a rebellion Adam a
rebellion they were upset yeah 100% but
Insurrection nobody was stabbing people
and come on Rob when you were there that
day how how was it how was the weather
protest
fellas Rob actually tried to climb the
fence couldn't make it he put up the
Raptors for wasn't there okay we're not
trying to get Rob in trouble a family
guy so but uh just looks like he but I
but I what I'm saying is I think these
guys who he's going up against really
are uh some smart lowkey underground
faceless type of people that you don't
know who they are but they're sitting
around reading everything finding a way
to take him down and by the way some
dark credit going to those guys
seriously I believe some real dark
credit so uh uh uh uh by the way the
lawyer that's representing Trump the
lawyer she's a Syrian she's a Syrian the
girl yeah she's kind of attractive
what's her name uh lauran Laura I don't
know what her name is but she's a Syrian
she came out to the
she's a Syrian she came out well listen
the syrians have a alen alen Hab alen
Haba picture they're
aan 198 she only 39 years old yeah she
came from from Iraq she came from Iraq
she's from her parents I the way she
talks she's a boss oh she's a stud she
good for you pretty attractive she's
like a young she's married she's married
Adam Sor married I'm not worried about
that just saying she's kind of looks
like a young um she remind have the
lawyer the lawyer from what's it called
Johnny Depp's lawyer she's like in the
same hot yeah yeah those eyes right
there we'll tell you I dare go ahead and
sue my client Su my Cent see what I do
to you dare go
ahead alen Al I love her she's awesome
all right guys we're gonna get some red
flags out there with that language she's
good listen I'm I'm in I'm in the hunt
for my friend Vincent osana I'm looking
for Vincent osana we saw a few
candidates yesterday for Vincent osana
and you know I realized too I know you
had the waitress the sushi waitress
Republican women conservative women way
hotter than left Democrat I went to Mar
Lago just the lawn everybody's happy and
it was a moment and Adam when's the last
time you went to like a democratic
function like what are those like just
Chuck Schumer in the in the corner like
everybody's just angry why is everybody
angry I've actually never been actually
that's not true I went to a Hillary uh
fundraiser of course you did 2015 how
was it I it was at a mansion in Miami
that my buddy owned so I'm going to go
but uh were the women like how many
women were there it was all gay guys it
was
amazing you were there Tom you were
there oh my God that's so funny and just
by the way Hot Rob is there any way pack
he could just do that poll just just
which party which conserv Republican or
Democrat I will say that they definitely
make better wives why would you say that
the conservative why would you classier
women make better wives I mean I would
say that most of the sex workers only
fans party girls are a lot of times hot
liberals with daddy issues wow good wow
not like I've done any research on this
but based on my calculation I'm just
very interested but uh yeah sorry but
you keep going to church bro you're
going to find find your every Sunday I'm
proud of you gen you think Alabama the
last debate matters or is it done done I
I think after yesterday it's probably
done for the following reasons we are 2
weeks from
Thanksgiving and you look at all the
history of the um we keep starting
earlier and earlier on this political
process and so in two weeks is
Thanksgiving and then we get into um
bowl games and holiday and a lot of
things going on and the only major
economic news that will come out um
unless just like a market crash or
something it's going to be Black Friday
everybody's going to be interested to
see how how revved up or how much U dry
powder did the American Consumer still
have in terms of credit and the ability
to go spend on a Black Friday and
digital Monday or whatever it is and
your just made up holiday cyber yeah
Cyber Monday and then all of a sudden
it's going to be it's going to be
January and so I don't think the next
debate really matters I think we've
narrowed it to four people and people
saw those four people last night and you
could argue that they were all as good
as they're probably going to get I don't
see you know what I mean why do you say
four people or five on stage eliminate
someone no because I I I call Christy
and Scott kind of the fourth you know
what I mean that but they're both gone
you mean if Christy eats Scott then he's
going to be Allin one by the way did you
get the references that Chris chrisy
kept saying last night he's like yeah
things are getting heavier and larger
out here it's like you're really said he
goes and you know what food stamps we
never had food ex we just ate everything
that's why I think the next debate
doesn't matter because we're about to
get distracted by normal endof year
stuff and unless the war gets much worse
you know dear Lord please no um or if
the economy really has something
terrible happened dear Lord please no
then we've got then we have Black Friday
and then we're in the bowl games or in
the holiday and then America is going to
wake up two weeks before the Super Bowl
and it says you know honey where's my
voter registration card we are going to
vote and they're all going to wake up
but I think they've seen everything
they're going to see I don't see Haley
any better than she was last last night
and previous even though she was a
little rattled last night and I see
think you've seen DeSantis as good as
presidential as poised as you're going
to see him good answers and then you've
we've seen Vivic trying to be a uniter
and then just getting back on event and
says heck I'm just going to be me okay
so Pat let's say that that debate
doesn't matter can I just give one
little quick an by way none of that
matters because Trump's got a 25 I just
gonna say that and then just that's the
punchline think about uh by the way
great Point Tom uh the next debate the
fourth debate the last debate I believe
is what it is yeah is in Alabama on
December 6th yeah so you went you guys
were in Milwaukee you said it was sort
of like a it was in the middle of summer
it was fun it was a party Vibe then you
go to California Reagan Library amazing
then you come to Miami Adrien AR Center
awesome the weather was great the vibe
was great and then right after
Thanksgiving you go to freaking Alabama
ain't nobody trying to go to
Alabama and there will be more people in
the stadium down the street in
Tuscaloosa than watching the debate
because Trump's going to do a rally
there probably with Tommy tville I'm
assuming or or University of Alabama is
playing for one of the four seeds in a
college football play no no not this
year they already have two losses I
America is going to say did you say
college football playoffs so so Adam it
like and Tom for all of us I know it's
still a a year away but let's just say
God forbid they play this Tom fery no
pun attendant Tom Tomy and uh Tom FY Tom
and uh Trump can't run Trump's
completely out who does who do they vote
for who does the Republican uh party put
number one out of all those we we'll let
you know no I'm saying if you had the
guess right now who goes number one Tim
Scott duh well I think well I think if
if the primaries are right now right now
um and no Trump zero Trump if there was
no Trump no Trump wow that's you know
the inheritance Factor on that's pretty
big you got to do some algebra on who
inherits those votes s so Des Santa
probably I think it Go V dog what he
just said is very important where is
Maga gonna go that's that win VC they
would go to D Santa no they would not no
way after all the that he talking I
think after last night it would shock
you how many of the angry magot go to
the 100% I'm telling you guys sleep on
him don't sleep on VC bro they're not
going to run Des demonus they're going
for VC VC was Donald Trump last night he
said the same stuff anti-china no more
war yelling at everybody off by December
by December you're also going to see uh
probably both Scott and Christie concede
their positions and we're going to see
an inheritance factor in the South
Carolina Iowa and New Hampshire Poland
yeah but they're not they're inheriting
1% of the electorat Hing a ton what do
they got what does Scott have he has 2%
christe's not even on there
what five and a half% up per play and
that's going to go to
Trump trump would make a video
supporting s what number does that say
14 141 Trump got a 42 and a half point
lead yeah yeah he's just running up the
score at this bro I'm telling you right
now Trump would make a video from jail
supporting VC and it would be hilarious
yeah guys can we just have a quick
moment of silence for my guy Doug beram
he got crossed over in a basketball game
for the first debate hang on hang on got
his Achilles ripped off still showed up
the second debate in a boot bigger than
Ron de santis he didn't make it to the B
shout out Doug Rob and itot and it was
his foot all the way to the bottom of
the boot the Rob that town fooler right
there I'm going to say right here Doug
beram ran to elevate his position
because he wants to be secretary of
agriculture that's a great call oh my
God record that just keep that in the
tank Thomas ell yeah yeah you really
went on a limb right there okay so
tomorrow tomorrow we can talk talk talk
but tomorrow we got Vic here cannot wait
which is going to be fantastic Tom vivec
will be here tomorrow Rob we're
confirmed with that or no we're good to
go as far as I'm aware okay and it's
going to be 9:00 a.m. it's going to go
back to the morning time that we have
with VC lots to talk about um if there's
any questions you have uh uh tweet at
Patrick B David let me know what
questions you have for if you want to
ask to ask him any questions he'll be
with us tomorrow for a full two hours I
got a lot of other questions I want to
go through with him as well business you
know how he's seeing things going on the
question you asked right now was a great
question as well what if Trump is not in
it where does he think magga voters are
going to go is he going to pick up the
magga voters it be interesting to see
interesting to see what he says about
potential cabinet members if he's
willing to go out on directional who's
your cabinet he's got to select 11
people and he's going to end up with a
lot of insiders they can't all be
offsiders be interested to know what
thanks gang uh and also make a note of
this December 6th at our club 5990 live
in for laudale I'll be doing a town hall
with RFK okay with RFK 5990 live what
happened you're pointing fingers no I'm
saying that's the same date as the RNC
debate yeah wow so December 6th same day
as the RNC debate we're going to be
doing the RFK uh uh uh we're going to be
doing the RFK Town Hall uh those of you
that are VIP that's all all sold out
anyways you can't buy the VIPs that sold
out within the first couple hours you'll
be able to send questions those who are
at the second part if we don't have any
questions to go to with the VIP we'll
come to you if you haven't yet
registered go to 5990 live.com again go
to 599 live.com VIPs are sold but we
still have a couple tickets left on the
other two having said that we'll see you
tomorrow with vvec 9:00 a.m. take care
everybody bye-bye
bye-bye